welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and with spiderman no way home just a
few mere weeks away everybody has been
wondering just what peter parker's life
is going to look like after this new
spider-man 3 hits theaters because not
only have the stakes never been higher
for a lean clean spider teen from queens
when the spider-verse comes to mess up
the routine but tom holland himself had
been making a sweat lately by casting
doubts on his future as the wisecracking
arachnid kid child man but hey luckily
for us sony pictures executive amy
pascal saved the day by announcing three
news tom hall and spider-man movies set
in the mcu right and plus with venom 2
ending with inky and the bane in the mcu
and morbius including posters of
spider-man and a whole ass michael
keaton as vulture everything should be
totally cool right everything it seems
like everything's fine uh yeah
technically not exactly look i hate to
be the bearer of bad news here i really
do but both sony executive amy pascal's
comments about the next spider-man
trilogy as well as the title no way home
itself kind of feel like very strong
indicators that this film noah home will
probably end with peter parker stuck in
a meshed up sony vs pocket reality with
no way back to his home mcu universe for
some time well okay let's go ahead and
speculate speculation nation starting
with breaking down what amy actually
said during her big announcement of
sony's continued workings with marvel
studios because amy be sounded mighty
suspicious mighty suspicious amy said
this is not the last movie that we are
going to make with marvel this is not
the last spider-man movie we are going
to make this next spider-man movie with
tom holland and marvel it's just not
part of
we're we're thinking of doing this as
three films and now we're going to go on
to the next three this is not the last
of our mcu movies okay so the only
things amy pascal has actually confirmed
with this quote are one a continued
partnership with marvel studios two
three new spider-man films that will be
made in partnership with marvel and
three that the next film
singular will involve tom holland as far
as i could glean amy pascal did not
announce a new tom holland spider-man
trilogy just that he'll be in the next
film until she says that that's all we
heard that's all she said batana wait a
minute wait a minute the most sketchy
thing about what amy pascal just said is
that she says but it's just not it's
just not what amy what were you going to
say well if i were to guess i strongly
hypothesized that amy pascal was just
going to say that the next spider-man
film was just not going to be in the
main mcu universe and here's why i think
this i think the answer to this lies
entirely within that very box peter
parker is going to be lugging around
throughout the entire course of this
movie and if you haven't seen my past
video on what could be inside of this
box i highly recommend that you watch
that video before you watch this one but
in a nutshell i suggest that this box is
a pocket reality prison that professor
oak gives peter ash ketchum parker to go
chase down the new visitors from the
sony spiderburst and catch them all and
trap them into this one big meshed
together sony pocket reality universe in
this big magic pokeball hypercube a
pocket reality seemingly protected by
symbols similar to those sanctum
markings the wizards of the mcu use to
protect the mcu planet it's what keeps
dormammu out however once fred daphne
and shaggy scooby do this and trap
your you know sam raby doc ox your mark
webb electros and possibly even your tom
hardy venom symbiotes into the sony
playstation and strange is about to
channel all of the sony playstation
energy from the sony cube back to their
respective universes this is when
strange is going to tell peter the fate
of all of these intruders that peter
literally just went around and caught
just rounded up like right before he's
about to send all these ghosts back to
their respective realities he's like oh
by the way you just sent all these
people in the box to die and peter's
like well
gotta take the box even though they are
technically his enemies from different
universes he refuses to let them die and
why does he do this well i mean peter
parker is just a good person but also i
would say that the power over life and
death um is a pretty big power to have
and you know i hear that uh with great
power there must also come great
responsibility and that is to me what is
going to be the major theme of this
movie i mean this movie is literally
going to start with steve not having a
blues clue how to act responsibly around
an impressionable child after wong
specifically told him not to cast the
spell and the new no way home trailer
very much intentionally has doctor
strange go out of his way to shove all
of that multiverse blame on an awkward
teenager because arusham forbid the
arrogant stephen strange make a mistake
i mean he's a sorcerer supreme so why
would he make a mistake it's obviously
got to be the the boy's fault and hey
our friends at upstart want you to be
able to open up the gift of getting out
from under credit card debt this holiday
season and i know you can't really wrap
that and put it under a tree but trust
me it's a really great gift i will
literally take 20 of those but upstart
can help you make that final payment so
that you can break the cycle of debt and
get ahead upstart is a fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online and whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upsart to get one fixed monthly
payment an upstart knows that you are
more than just your credit score and is
expanding access to affordable credit
and rather than looking at credit score
alone upstart considers other factors
like your income current employment and
credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loan and you can check
your rate without impacting your credit
score in minutes for loans between
thousand to fifty thousand dollars and
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan so find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com new rockstars that's
upstart.com new rockstars and use our
url to let them know that we sent you
upstart.com
new rockstars and because this
responsibility is so great instead of
leaving all of these spider-man villains
to die i predict that peter parker will
pull a sony stark and sacrifice his life
and home as he knows it to become the
protector of this new sony reality you
know much like his new mentor doctor
strange because you know bearded science
bros for life and you know because peter
parker isn't the only hero in this movie
much like peter will you know take cues
and learn lessons from doctor strange
doctor strange himself will also likely
be schooled in a lesson in
responsibility as peter's actions fueled
by his immense sense of responsibility
starts to lift strange's own arrogance
as he heads into multiverse of madness
because you gotta remember then doctor
strange one the main thing that he
learned was selflessness his arrogance
is still very much intact and i can't
imagine a doctor strange more arrogant
than a doctor strange who just saved
half of the universe from thanos and
this is why i believe that sony has
officially stated morbius as not
occurring within the mcu main universe
despite having posters of remy
spider-man and references to venom in
the trailers because the universe that
morbius is in technically isn't within
the main mcu universe it would be a
separate pocket universe within the
overall mcu multiversal continuity and
this box is what i believe will
exemplify amy pascal and sony's
partnership with marvel studios marvel
studios would effectively be giving sony
permission to rent out space in this box
within the mcu where technically
everything that happens within this box
is part of mcu continuity without having
the events of what happens in this box
affect the actual canon of the main mcu
universe that we know because sony and
marvel at the end of the day are two
different companies with two different
creative visions and so all in all and
again i hate to be the one to say it and
god do i hope i'm wrong but spider-man
no way home could very well be the start
of sony's you know
semi-reclamation of their spider-man
character with sony producing their own
spider-man films inside of this doctor
strange box for a while until you know
the main mcu universe needs your peter
parker's or your mouse morales for their
bigger crossover events like secret wars
avengers movie or something because
regardless of how we feel about it sony
has always been dead set on building
their own sony verse of spider-man
characters outside of their deal with
marvel studios so peter parker was never
going to stay forever but hey what do
you guys think about this possibility of
peter potentially leaving the mcu for a
little while let us know in the comment
section below my beautiful nerd baby
children but of course you can follow me
at mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird and some wild
theories but more importantly please
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media especially on twitter and
on youtube when you do on youtube make
sure to hit that notification bell so
you get notifications every time we
upload a video and also please be sure
to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so you
can get cool shirts like this i love you
guys so much uh thank you guys so much
for watching and i'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you